What I believe is that everything needs to be investigated.
and that everything should not be feared to be investigated.
All contracts
of administrations under suspicion,
to be investigated in any institution,
in any
autonomous community and in any municipality,
because he who is condemned nothing fears.
What does seem evident is that there is 1 corruption.
systemic
in the Spanish state and this is no longer 1 impression,
but 1 statement,
well if we talk about politics,
or if we talk about financial and economic appointments,
well if we talk about the state security forces,
or even if we talk about the justice apparatus.
We did it in the monarchy
with the King Emeritus or with the case,
we did it to us in politics,
also achieved this in large entrepreneurs
and in the eh bank bosses.
And there have been and there are in the 2nd of communication,
that have covered up and justified everything that happened.
And that is what we are seeing now.
They move Koldo or they move
Luceño,
either they are called Medina or they are called Tomás.
It doesn't matter,
because it seems that some of them took
too much to the letter that we will go out
better,
as one former president would say,
we'll get better the worse,
for me, the better